وتنطلق خلق النايل منذ ايام قليله تبعد
جميع العرب بشوق وترقب الصاروخ الذي حلق
برواد الفضاء عاليا حاملا معه مركبه
فضائيه نقلت رائدي الفضاء السعوديين علي
القرني وريان برناوي المركبه كما الرواد
شهدت طريقا طويلا قبل ان تتمكن من دخول
التاريخ انها مركبه دراغون فماذا نعرف
عنها
[موسيقى]
بدا العمل على تطوير مركبه دراغون عام
وكاله ناسا الامريكيه للفضاء من الشركات
تقديم مقترحات لتطوير مركبات فضائيه صالحه
للاغراض التجاريه وامنه ايضا لنقل رواد
الفضاء وفي 2006 وقع اختيار ناسا على سبيس
اكس الشركه المطوره للراكز رحله دراغون
الرسميه الاولى كانت عام 2010 ونجحت بان
تكون المركبه الفضائيه التجاريه الاولى
التي تعود سليمه من مهمتها وبعدها بعامين
بدات رحلاتها المنتظمه الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه واقتصرت رحلاتها على الامداد
التجاري لاحقا طورت شركه اصدارا ثانيا من
المركبه مخصصا لنقل الركاب اطلقت عليه اسم
دراغون 2
يبلغ طول المركبه مترين وتسعين سنتيمترا
وقطرها ثلاثه امتار و60 سم
وتقدر كتلتها بحدود
4200 كيلو جرام تستخدم اربعه بطاريات لثيم
بالمير ويقدر عمرها الافتراضي بعامين كحد
اقصى كما انها قادره على حمل سبعه ركاب في
كل رحله
اما اسم المركبه فتم اقتباسه من اغنيه قف
اسطوح المدير التنفيذي لشركه سبيس اكس
ايلون ماسك اسم المركبه من اغنيه
ردا على كل من سخر منه او توقع فشل مشروعه
2020 وحملت على متنها رايدي الفضاء روبرت
بنكن ودوغلس هارلي لتصبح سبيس اكس اول
شركه تجاريه تطلق رحلات للفضاء ماهوله
بشريه اما رحله المركبه الاخيره فقد كانت
على راس صاروخ فالكون تسعه التابعي ايضا
لسبيكس اكس وعادت للارض بواسطته هبوط مظلي
على مسطح مائل
المركبه مزوده بنظام اطلاق متكامل يضم
ثمانيه محركات من نوع
قادر على دفع المركبه بسرعه فائقه بعيدا
عن الصاروخ في حاله الطوارئ كما ان لديها
نظاما يسمح بانقاذ الحموله في حاله الوقوف
الاضطراري للاطلاق يتم تحميل غاز الهيليوم
على الضغط اولا وقبل ساعتين من موعد
الاطلاق يدخل رواد الفضائل المركبه وقبل
40 دقيقه من نقطه الصفر يتم تشغيل نظام
الانطلاق مع بدء تعبئه الوقود وبالرغم من
ان المركبه تتسع لسبعه ركاب الا ان ناسا
ترسل اربع فقط كحد اقصى في هذه الرحلات
[موسيقى]